[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN FITZPATRICK: Hi, everybody.
It's great to be
here with you today.
My name's Jen Fitzpatrick.
And I lead our GEO
Group here at Google.
My team is obsessed
with understanding
everything there is to
know about the real world.
And we want to bring that
insight and understanding
of the real world to
people around the globe,
helping them navigate, explore,
and decide with confidence.
We do this with three main
experiences-- Google Maps,
which lets you leave home
knowing that you'll never
get lost, local search, the
ability to come to Google
and ask anything you
might need to know
about a local business, whether
it's one in your neighborhood,
or one far around the world;
and Google My Business, which
enables millions of businesses
to be found on Google
and share what's most
unique about them.
Over a billion people
around the world
now use Google Maps
and local search.
But the impact
doesn't stop there.
We also see incredible
opportunity for businesses
to benefit from this deep
understanding of location
in the real world.
And I'm really excited about
partnering with everyone
here today to build
location-based products
and services that have a big
impact on your businesses, too.
I wanted to start
today by jumping back
in time a little bit.
It's not too long
ago that if you
wanted to go
someplace unfamiliar,
you had to pull
out a paper atlas
and plan your route in advance.
Any of you remember
having that experience?
Feels like a distant memory.
But I'm pretty sure most of
us can think back to a time
when that was the default.
So 11 years ago,
Google Maps set out
with the audacious goal
of mapping the world.
We wanted to digitize those
paper maps, and the paper
Yellow Pages, too.
And we wanted to do it not
just for one neighborhood,
or even one country.
We wanted to do it for the
entire world-- every street
and every surface, every
business, every detail-- all
of it.
Since then, we've not only
brought maps online all
around the world, we've also
done things like help people
experience corners of the
planet that they might otherwise
never get to see, from the
tops of the highest mountains
to the depths of the oceans.
And of course, along the way,
we brought all those experiences
onto mobile devices,
as well, giving users
everywhere a trusted
guide to the real world
that they can bring
with them anywhere
to help them get where
they're going fast,
and to find the best places
to visit along the way.
To build these sorts of
powerful user experiences,
we've had to also build out
an incredibly rich and complex
understanding of the real world.
And it turns out that
the underlying data
that powers these consumer
mapping experiences
can also fuel some incredibly
powerful enterprise
use cases, as well.
Today, we have over
three million developers,
and over 10,000 paying
customers using our Maps APIs
to do everything from
visualizing points
on a map to routing and
planning for deliveries,
to doing things like
preprograming TV remotes based
on their location.
And looking forward, we're
building on these capabilities
and bringing together all of our
both historical and real-time
knowledge about the
world, combining it
with things like machine
learning and our cloud compute
capabilities, and using
that to provide business
with even more insights and
predictive capabilities.
So today, I want to share with
you three key ways that we're
seeing enterprises currently
take advantage of our Google
Maps data and services to
help grow their businesses,
and also share some
examples of what we think
is possible together today.
We see clearly how
Google Maps can
help you build better
experiences for your customers,
how it can help you
optimize your business,
and how it can help enable
smart, strategic decisions.
So I talked earlier today
about how we're constantly
seeking ways to make our
consumers' experiences better
with Google Maps.
And we see that same appetite
from our enterprise partners--
finding ways to use the
power of Google Maps
to deliver better experiences
to their end users.
For example, we
see auto companies
like Audi, Tesla, and BMW
leveraging our local business
listings in their
in-car nav systems
to help their drivers
easily find and get
to millions of businesses
and points of interest
around the world.
And we've also
helped transform how
people are getting around
today by doing things
like powering the base
maps and navigation
experiences for companies
like Uber, Lyft, and others.
In retail, we're
helping companies
like Crate and Barrel,
Target, and Best Buy
connect online actions
to offline foot traffic,
and in doing, so
helping them to drive
more feet into their stores.
And we see savvy online
sellers also doing things
like taking advantage of our
autocomplete capabilities
to make it easier
for the users to type
an address into their
shopping cart, which
does things like lead directly
to fewer abandoned carts,
and increased conversion rates.
Let me talk about a
fun one for a minute.
Any of you remember
going to Disney World
and getting a giant, complicated
paper map of the park?
And it's crowded.
And you're trying to figure out,
how do I get to Space Mountain?
And on no, if I go
there right now,
is the line going
to be super long?
Disney's a super fun
place, but it can also
be overwhelming and
incredibly frustrating.
And so Disney Parks
had this grand vision
of building an in-park
app experience that
would let you do everything
from understand what the wait
times were to make
reservations for the rides
you wanted to go to,
and help you easily get
around anywhere in the park.
Well, it turns out that
to do these things well,
one of the things you need
is an incredibly detailed--
highly detailed-- digital map
of every corner of Disney.
And so several years
back, we embarked
on a long-term, multi-year
partnership with Disney
to create just that.
And as we got into
it, along the way,
we discovered that
there was a lot more
we could do beyond
that, too-- fun things
like enabling contextual,
location-based experiences.
So if you've got a son or
a daughter who's really
into Goofy, you can get a
notification in real time
that tells you when Goofy
happens to be nearby.
We also did things
like incorporating
all the in-park transit
systems and lighting up
turn-by-turn directions.
So now, you can literally
find the fastest way
to get to Splash Mountain
right now, whether it's
walking or taking the monorail.
This was a really fun project
for us-- a great partnership.
And we're super
pleased to have helped
make the Happiest Place on
Earth just a little bit happier
for all of Disney's
many visitors.
Let's talk about
another fun one briefly.
You just heard about Pokemon
Go from Phil and crew.
And their story is
a phenomenal example
of what's possible today for
consumer experiences leveraging
Google Maps.
Pokemon Go took
our mapping data,
and built an incredible
augmented reality game
on top of it.
And if their early
success is any indication,
we fully expect that
we're going to see
a lot more fun and interesting
augmented reality experiences
coming in the near
future, both for consumers
and for enterprises.
Here's another one.
As the Internet of
Things scales up,
location services are
becoming even more essential
for creating smart experiences.
I don't know about
you, but who would
have thought a few years
ago that everything
from your thermostat to your
light bulb to your refrigerator
is going to be connected,
and be able to be controlled
by your smartphone?
But it's not so
crazy to think about.
In fact, it's not so
crazy at this point
to think about a world in
the not-too-distant future
where literally every
device in your household
is connected in
one way or another.
And so imagine how cool would
be if your light switches
and your thermostats
know that you're
about to pull into
your driveway,
and that it's you coming
home, not your kids.
And so it can turn on your
lights and the air conditioning
according to your preferences
right before you get home.
Or knowing your car's
about to pull out
of the driveway, your
alarm and your door lock
can automatically
disarm so you can
carry your groceries
into the house
without having to put them down.
In a connected world,
location awareness
can fuel all sorts
of new and fun ways
to interact with the things
in our physical surroundings.
That gives you a
very brief taste
of some of the many ways that
we are seeing businesses build
really game-changing
experiences for their customers
on top of our data and
insights about the world.
So the second big
area that we're
seeing major innovation
from enterprises
is in optimizing
their core business.
One of our core
strengths in Maps
is increasingly becoming
our understanding
of real-time traffic data.
And many businesses,
especially those that
are in the business of
moving things in the world,
tap into this rich data to help
streamline their operations,
and optimize their workforce.
So from transport and
logistic companies
to things like emergency
relief and disaster response,
we're seeing more and
more organizations
putting Maps at the center
of their operations,
and helping them more
efficiently locate, manage,
and monitor their resources.
So one example, Fleetminder
used the Google Maps APIs
to map their vehicle locations
so their dispatchers could
view where they were, and
send them real-time updates
as things were changing.
And what we saw from
them is that this
drove direct savings that went
right to their bottom line.
So to give you an
example, their CIO
has told us that by using
Google's mapping solutions,
it's help them cut their
inefficient driving in half,
and it's helped reduce
incorrect deliveries that they
were providing by 20%.
But now, build on
that a little further.
And let's imagine
what's possible
when that rel-time traffic
understanding can get baked
much more deeply
into your systems,
or as we're beginning
to be able to do,
also predict what traffic
or movement might look
like under different
conditions in the real world
in the future.
Imagine being able to ask things
like, how many extra taxis
should I have at 5:00 PM
in New York on a Thursday
when the Yankees are
playing, or can I
guarantee a 15-minute delivery
window to my customers
when there's a Beyonce concert
happening in LA on Thursday
night?
These are increasingly
the types of questions
that customers are asking
us to help them with.
They want to optimize and
route their fleets better based
on changing conditions
in the real world.
And we're really excited to be
giving more and more businesses
the insights that they
need to flexibly respond
to real-time,
real-world conditions.
Finally, our deep
understanding of location,
combined with machine
learning and the cloud,
provides incredible potential
to help enterprises make
smart, strategic decisions.
An example-- there's a
German insurance company
called WGV Insurance.
And they created a risk
map on top of our data
to understand both where
their policyholders are,
and to help the model with
different risk management
scenarios.
So in less than six
weeks, they were
able to take their
policyholder information,
overlay it together with things
like flood areas, weather
reports, and other
types of geodata,
to help them make better
decisions about how
to financially model
their business.
And I think it's a testament to
the power of the sort of data
and tooling that they were
able to fundamentally shift
how they did risk
assessment modeling in such
a short period of time.
We also see a lot of
businesses asking questions
about the real world that either
they don't have answers to,
or that they're
spending very, very
heavily on physical
infrastructure to answer.
And this is a big area
where understanding
of how the world moves
can help influence
important commercial
decisions out there
in the physical world.
To give you one
example, we're currently
in conversations with a
major city that traditionally
has spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on things
like putting sensors
in their roads,
or sending surveys out
to homes to find out
things about traffic
and commuting patterns.
And we're talking with them
now about how they can instead
use our real-time traffic
data, machine learning,
and predictive analytics
to help make urban planning
decisions easier, faster, more
accurate, and very importantly,
far, far less expensive.
And it's just one example of
how our rich data and analytics
capabilities can really drive
change in the way companies
go about gathering information
about physical movement
in the world.
Just two weeks ago, we
announced the acquisition
of Urban Engines, who
built a location analytics
business around use cases like
transit and transportation.
We want to be able to help
answer questions like,
where are the next areas of
urban sprawl going to be?
And can we use that
information to decide
where to build the
next highway, or where
I should put my
next retail store,
or even how much retail staff
should I plan to have on hand
next Friday night based on what
the predicted level of foot
traffic nearby is going to be?
We're really excited about
the new opportunities
that this deep location
intelligence can
fuel, building on top of
this rich comprehensive
understanding of the physical
world and how it moves.
Over the last
decade, Google Maps
has made some
incredible strides.
And yet, I really,
quite honestly,
feel like we're just at
the beginning of something
new and even more exciting.
It's particularly exciting to
me that the types of problems
that businesses are looking
to us to help them solve
are exponentially more
challenging than they
were even a few years back.
A few years ago, most
of the conversations
we were having with
businesses were
around things like
how could we help
them visualize the real world?
How could we do things
like show some custom
data on top of a map?
But today, enterprises
are increasingly
asking us about much more
sophisticated location
problems-- ones that involve
planning, spending, insights,
movements, predictions.
In essence, we're
helping businesses move
beyond just
visualizing the world,
and helping them make
major, real-world decisions.
And at the center of
it all is location,
and this understanding of
how the real world moves.
So as you've heard today, the
combination of our raw location
understanding and movement
data from the billion users
of our consumer products,
combined with Google's machine
learning and cloud
compute power,
can change the game
very, very quickly
for a lot of industries,
from retail to real estate,
transportation to
logistics, and more.
So if you or your customers
operate in the physical world,
then location should
matter deeply to you.
And if it does, we
invite you to talk to us.
What fuels our
imagination more than
anything are
real-world problems.
And we'd love to invite you
all into a conversation with us
about what your
business needs are,
and the problems that you're
most looking to solve.
We are just at the
beginning of helping
businesses unlock the potential
from this understanding
of location.
And we're very excited to
partner with all of you
to bring these
opportunities to life.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]